bonjour yan monplaisir
donc je remonte le temps vous êtes un
vice président de la ceni de martinique
et chef de file de ba payant chance hier
et aujourd'hui encore vous présidez la
séance plénière qui se déroule à plateau
à première question qu'on va vous poser
il ya mon plaisir puisque on se souvient
des propos d' alfred marie-jeanne il ya
une dizaine de jours sur la radio arrels
dr alfred marie-jeanne le président du
conseil exécutif qui parle de divorce
avec vous yan monplaisir vous n'étaient
pas en martinique au moment de cette
déclaration
l'avez vous rencontré oui je les ai
rencontrés hier à l'issue de la matinée
donc entre à l'heure du déjeuner nous
avons eu un échange en tête à tête franc
direct franc direct soit parce que c'est
notre tempérament à tous les deux pour
trois et très courtois
je pense que quand on est en tête à tête
on est on est un peu plus soi-même on
est moins dans le show off
ouais et donc nous avons nous avons
parlé très directement je souhaitais le
faire avant de faire toute déclaration
d'ailleurs vous avez vu que je résistais
un petit peu comme vous m'avez
interrogez vous et vos collègues vos
confrères et que vous vouliez que je
vous exprime ce qui est normal ce qui
est normal puisque je veux pas atténuer
la gravité de ce qui s'est passé je
n'étais pas en martinique je n'avais pas
eu d'échangés directs avec le président
de l'exécutif et il me paraissait
nécessaire que nous ayons cet échange
franc et direct à l'avant que je ne
m'exprime alors heures que c'était que
s'est il dit lors de cet échange est ce
que ce différend et définitif au gaz et
à un coup de colère sur un moment bien
précis peut-être ensuite une question
d'un auditeur
je suis comme ça souvent dire je pense
que je pense qu'un peu de ça je pense
que si vous voulez savoir plus si vous
voulez en savoir plus il faut poser la
question directement alfred marie jeanne
qui est celui qui a fallu qu'il ya eu ce
coup de sang je la lui ai posé moi et
j'avais voulu comprendre et il m'a
répondu qu' il était agacé par la
déclaration de certains chefs
d'entreprise et qu'il trouvait que mon
implication avec eux
avec ses chefs d'entreprise là était et
est de nature à créer une forme de
trouble où je dirais le gênait parce que
ça ça a témoigné peut-être d'une forme
de complicité et d'approbation de
certaines déclarations
alors bon moi je lui ai dit qu'elle
était mon dessin je veux rassembler tous
les martiniquais on va pas faire
d'emplois on va pas donner du travail
aux martiniquais
si on tourne le dos aux entreprises et
il faut écouter les angles et chefs
d'entreprise il faut pas céder aux chefs
d'entreprise le rôle du politique est
précisément de conduire une politique
dans le sens de l'intérêt général
mais si on additionne les intérêts
particuliers
à condition que les intérêts
particuliers dans le sens de l'intérêt
général
on sera beaucoup plus efficace et donc
il n'est pas question selon moi que l'on
essaie de construire le développement
d'un pays sans y associer les forces
économiques
c'est ce qui se passe dans tous les pays
du monde dans tous les grands pays mais
aussi dans les petits pays alors des
manques deuxième à sainte lucie à
dominique à trinidad dans tous ses
petits pays
le monde économique est écouté par le
monde politique
sur le plan politique strictement
politique est ce qu'on va dire que
alfred marie-jeanne et yan monplaisir
vont continuer à cheminer ensemble
jusqu'à la fin du mandat de 2021 la main
dans la main oui je l'espère en tout cas
je l'espère ce qui me concerne ce sera
le cas qu'est ce qui compte pour moi moi
j'en ai un vous savez je pense que tout
le monde en a assez un petit peu des
cancans des bagarres des complots etc je
ne suis pas dans cette démarche là je me
suis engagé dans cette dans ce contrat
que nous avons soumis aux martiniquais
que les martiniquais ont validé je me
suis engagé dans ce contrat en sachant
très bien que ce serait pas facile
ouais en sachant qu'il y aurait des
écueils en sachant qu'il y aurait des
difficultés à surmonter mais ce qui
compte pour moi c'est l'intérêt de notre
pays
je souffre de voir de voir la martinique
ne plus être dans le peloton de ne plus
être le premier territoire d'outre-mer
dans tous les domaines nous ne sommes
encore fortement certains gamins à
l'issue de cet entretien a été franche
entre alfred marie-jeanne et vous ce que
vous avez ressenti que bah écoutez vous
êtes explique
on repart de l'avant oui parce que je
lui ai rappelé d'abord que je suis
quelqu'un d'honnête et que mon
engagement n'est pas un engagement de
zoller et que si je ne suis pas d'accord
avec lui au point où je verrai la
nécessité de faire ça vous de le faire
savoir publiquement
je viendrai de lui dire avant et je
ferai une rupture franche mais que
autrement que autrement je m'
accommoderait de nos divergences de vues
est ce donc ce qu'il doit accepter lui
aussi on peut pas être d'accord il en a
convenu
nous ne pouvons pas d'accord sur tout
nous avons des divergences nous avons
des appréciations différentes de
certaines situations mais à partir du
moment où l'intérêt qu'est-ce que ça
produirait si j'étais allé à la prise
jusqu'au bout de la crise quel serait
l'intérêt pour la martinie puisque ça a
quand même estimé que c'était grave les
propos d'alfredo bariseau j'estime et je
lui ai dit alors il ya eu cette
explication entre deux leaders
politiques hier après midi
maintenant les martiniquais qu'est-ce
qui doit se dire ce matin est ce qu'il
ya des raisons de douter de ce grand
ensemble et pumba pays en chance qui ce
qui s'est déchirée qui se déchiraient
qui risque encore de se déchaîner
puisque n'est pas toujours d'accord sur
tout maintenant il faut pas qu il faut
qu il faut qu'on essaie de construire
ensemble pas seulement avec le pas
seulement avec le vent semblait avec
tous les martiniquais et donc il faut
que les martiniquais ils apprennent à se
mettre ensemble à travailler ensemble ce
que nous faisons c'est que nous
travaillons nous travaillons aussi bien
si le dire sa soutane diane montrose
marinette orpik est en train de créer un
fonds pour permettre à des jeunes
entrepreneurs avec l'appui évidemment du
président parce que ça peut pas se faire
si marie jeanne est content mais qui est
en train de faire de créer ce fonds
karine rousseau qui a obtenu des
résultats exceptionnels c'est ce que
nous faisons nous travaillons pour la
marque alors le dos de l'autre fait
l'autre fait marquant de cette journée
d'hier c'était vers 19h 20h
l'intervention de l'élu cora bernabé de
l'opposition ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle présidente d'une
association d'une filière qui veut
développer le cacao et qui dit qu'elle
est peut être juge et partie mais en
fait elle est élue à la présidence de
cette association qui veut développer la
filière et puis il ya eu les
compréhensions selon crée l'impression
que des aides pourtant promise n'arrive
qu'on n'arrive pas et à se demande si
c'est pas si c'est parce qu'elle est
membre de l'opposition que c'était ne
vient pas est ce que vous envie de tout
ça moi ce que j'en dis c'est que c'est
que si c'était le cas je ne crois pas
que ce soit ce serait grave mais que
évidemment si ce ressenti existe et il
existe puisqu'elle l'a exprimé avec
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de beaucoup
de tension et donc c'était
nécessairement vrai et sincère et bien
il faut dans une preuve qu'il n'était
pas à l'ordre du jour
il faut lui apporter ses réponses à une
à une
une plénière c'est aussi fait pour
permettre aux élus de s'exprimer et
d'obtenir des réponses que quelquefois
ils n'arrivent pas obtenir autrement que
par ce biais là et quand on en arrive à
ces extrémités
c'est à dire ne pas pouvoir tenir des
élections à une extrémité hier lorsque
vous avez entendue sur ses déclarations
je commence donc aujourd'hui c'est que
ça avec ce livre sur comme l'a souligné
je pense que je pense que et je suppose
on ne peut pas dire je sais qu'elle a
tenté d'avoir des réponses
et si elle n'arrive pas à obtenir les
réponses elle peut se peut supposer à
tort ou à raison que c'est parce que l
un positionnement politique différent de
celui de la majorité alors on voit la
difficulté qu'il y à être à la fois dans
l'assemblée et en même temps à avoir des
activités qui requiert le soutien de
l'assemblée
on voit bien la difficulté pour elle
qu'elle a d'ailleurs exprimé en disant
écoutez si faussement naïve en mls qui
s'est passé pour cora bienabe sais pas
ce qui se passe pour beaucoup de marques
cliquet qui porte le projet monsieur
monsieur viotto il ne faut pas que ça se
reproduise j'ai personnellement puisque
j'étais chef d'entreprise j'ai
personnellement été victime de cela
c'est à dire d'un ostracisme qui
relevait uniquement de mon
positionnement politique qui n'était pas
celui qui était souhaitée certes vous
avez affirmé comprendre son désarroi à l
essai parce que c'est pour cela sans
doute que je comprends mieux
et c'est aussi par souci d'efficacité
parce qu'on ne sera pas efficace si il y
à un jugement qui se fait sur des
critères politiques et non pas sur des
critères d'intérêt de la martinique et
actrice est important ce n'est pas de
savoir si vous êtes au ppm au mime a eu
un mouvement quelconque
ce qui est important c'est que vous
soyez un martiniquais qui veut faire
quelque chose qui dont la martinique et
intérêts que ça se fasse une subvention
pas mal de savoir quel est le bon
politique des gens une subvention de 22
mille cinq cents euros l'explication de
louis boutrin c'est que le dossier est
en cours de destruction mais qu'il
manquait peut-être certaines pièces est
ce que c'est une réponse satisfaisante
au monde à seulement parce qu'ils trient
elle a évoqué la question de l'emploi de
la fin de ce mois ci cette aide c'est ed
harris pas je sais pas si c'est
satisfaisant ou pas mais ce qui n'est
pas satisfaisant c'est qu'un dossier
traîne pendant deux ans chez nous et
c'est ça que vous reproche beaucoup
c'est de cette et qui se disent il a
cité m mais c'est ce qu'on voudrait
prendre beaucoup de couteau reproche pas
à cette équipe pour projeter on leur
reproche de tout temps ou à l'examen des
dossiers par les collectivités je vous
rappelle que par exemple pour les fonds
européens
quand nous sommes arrivés avec 3 % qui
était engagé ce qui est anormal comme
rythme mais ça c'est le fonctionnement
c'est j'allais dire si je veux pas
blâmer l'administration puisque nous
sommes responsables de l'organisation de
l'ariège hier je me suis fait taper sur
les doigts par du shanxi le le président
de la commission finances de l'assemblée
me dire que nous n'avions nous avons eu
tort de dire dernier de la classe sur
l'utilisation des fonds européens
oui oui bon c'est une réalité ouais bon
alors écoutez il faut là aussi si vous
lécher une manière de voir les choses
peut-être que c'est parce que parce que
c'est fait vous reproche peut-être parce
que je suis je suis pragmatique je
regarde les choses comme elles sont elle
ne me font pas toujours plaisir
vous croyez que quand j'ai été dans le
dans le monde dans le monde économique
quand j'étais responsable quoique ça me
faisait plaisir quelques fois de me
trouver dans une situation compliquée
difficile sur le plan économique
ça fait pas plaisir mais si vous ne
regardez pas la réalité en face
si vous ne vous dites pas des choses
sont ce qu'elles sont comme dirait le
général de gaulle les choses étant ce
qu'elles sont vous n'arrivez pas à
avancer
donc il faut regarder la réalité lorsque
dans cette partie de cette réalité il
faut prendre des décisions qui vous
permettent de sortir d'une impasse
est ce que dans le cercle est minable
est ce que dans cette équipe
y a une capacité à voir des choses
telles qu'elles sont oui oui il y a
cette capacité
je pense je pense d'abord aux présidents
d'exécutifs alfred marie jeanne
c'est un pragmatique quand il a vu les
choses il modifie sa position il est
capable de modifier sa position mais il
faut et encore faut-il qu'ils voient
vous êtes un post réduction là vous
essayez de non jeu tout le monde le
connaît comme ça oui ça m a dit que
c'est quelqu'un de courageux
non je écoutez moi moi je regarde les
qualités et les défauts dit joël et
votre séduction essayer de vous pouvez
voir ça comme ça - non je suis
simplement je suis simplement quelques
là aussi de pratiquer je vous dis que
quand il a vu les choses il est capable
de prendre des décisions parce qu'il est
courageux simplement peut-être que
quelques fois dans son entourage
il y a précisément une espèce
d'atmosphère de complot il y a sans
doute aussi une une méfiance excessive
dans son entourage qui côté je voudrais
pas me faire de vous donner de noms je
pense que quelquefois il écoute il
écoute des sirènes par exemple par
exemple on pourrait supposer que
quelqu'un est intérêt à ce qu'ils
écoutent - un peu - iliad mon plaisir et
que écueil qu'on lui a eu lui souffler à
l'oreille
et puis voilà et puis il entend ça c'est
ça le malin moi c'est ça qu'on peut que
je lui reproche c'est qu'ils entendent
des sirènes
et puis quand il a entendu la sirène
quelques voix lui avait d'ailleurs je
lui dis je lui dis il ne reste très très
peu de temps
rapidement il ya eu ce coup de gueule
hier matin les élus qui ne sont pas à
l'heure pour le début de la séance
plénière est un manque de respect pour
vous c'est un manque de respect
vis-à-vis des habitants
c'est un manque de respect vis-à-vis de
l'assemblée et c'est une mare
d'inefficacité et de mauvaises mesures
du coup parce que pendant que nous
sommes là une heure eh bien nous payons
tous les salariés parce que c'est toute
une
c'est toute une une organisation une
plénière nous payons tous et toutes ces
personnes qui sont souvent des cadres
parce qu'ils sont obligés d'état pour
répondre éventuellement des questions
pendant une heure à ne rien faire eh
bien ça le le chef d'entreprise que je
suis ne peut pas l'accepter
la règle d'or c'est de respecter les
horaires et de respecter les autres
parce que c'est une réponse doit
s'imposer à soi même c'est une règle
d'efficacité également de politesse
d'efficacité et de respect merci d'avoir
été se battre avec nous il ya mon
plaisir
vice président de l'assemblée de
martinique et chef de file de banque
ayant chance bonne journée
[Musique]